[Music]
on reddit
there was this question is it there was
this question asked and it
says what positive impacts do you think
will come from covid19
reddit answered well number one it says
companies and schools will not force
people to come in when they are sick
so these are people right oh cool they
hope will be the positive
impact of covenants force you to come in
when they're sick
well your parents yeah and now the
school is gonna accept you if you're
sick if you have a flu or whatever right
i mean
it just wasn't a hard rule like don't
come if you're sick but now it's a hard
rule i see but people fake sick all the
[ __ ] time too
oh yeah i'm gonna dude if i was a teen
i'd be like i think i got the vids
yeah it's like the easiest thing ever
yeah you run the hot water put the
thermometer in there and put it in your
mouth and then you go
no way you're that you're not 106
degrees but now you just go i think i
feel a little bit sick isn't that scary
you go
and then you're like yeah stay home yeah
exactly that's nice true
uh this other one says the new skills
people have been learning
i've never even tried to plant anything
but i learned how to grow a garden this
year and now i have fresh peppers and
tomatoes
cool that's really cool that's really
cool yeah a lot of people decided to use
this time for
building skills i like that i think um
outdoorsy things like outdoor sports
off-roading just all this stuff is just
going crazy right now
surfing oh you mean people are doing it
yeah it's like social distancing
friendly sports
yeah and all this stuff yeah that's true
and it's taking everyone outdoors
oh i loved seeing hiking and
i think family time i started seeing
like groups of families
i mean you don't see it as much anymore
but in the beginning i saw that and i
was like that's so cool
there were big groups of families that i
saw walking around the neighborhood a
lot too
one of the members at my gym was like
man this quarantine's making me go crazy
about a two thousand dollar mountain
bike and he goes what am i kidding i
don't bike
he's like you never wrote it i did buy a
two thousand dollar mountain bike but
i'm using it you're like every week
now this guy's like i bought it and
wrote it once he goes like who am i
kidding [ __ ] am i
this isn't me that's fine he just kept
it
that's funny going back to the family
thing though someone wrote on one of
theirs that said
i've enjoyed the bonding with my family
normally my husband and i work full time
and our four-year-old son went to
preschool we decided to pull our son
from school and we both work from home
i know everything is crazy but we'll
never get this time together again
with immediate family yeah i haven't i
haven't actually seen my family i see my
family less now
than i did pre quarantine i would see
them like every other month
but now it's like i haven't seen them
since
march how about online like because oh
we mean we chat and stuff but like no
not in person in person and no i haven't
seen him at all
i see my dad like every couple of months
and he's scared that he's gonna give it
to tyka and i'm like you know
statistics show it's the other way
around but he just i guess loves taku so
much he doesn't want to
jump if he doesn't see anybody he thinks
he's invincible and he's like but
taika that's cute no another family one
though is
they wrote i have started seeing family
more regularly online playing games
i had no idea no idea about like jack
box it's been fun oh
cool it was fun it's been fun and it
would never have happened without the
pandemic
plus older family members are bored and
want to talk for literally an hour about
mundane stuff i've learned a lot about
them and i've never known
that i've never known my whole life why
do they do that they have no one to talk
to it's just so [ __ ] annoying though
it's rough
it's it's rough yeah not much over here
oh the cats are oh man they got out
earlier
that's gonna be you dude it won't be i
won't
i won't bore something you don't even
know you're doing it you think you're
gonna be connecting with people and
they're like i don't give a [ __ ] about
gardening or your snails bro
but there's interesting old geezers all
the time like you hear them sometimes on
like
joe rogan well i wish i knew them
because the ones that i know are like
you know i usually come in at 7 50.
today was 7 55.
yeah i was like whoa that's so weird
that's crazy
that's awesome did you see that new
penske commercial where the guy's in the
truck but then the dogs next to him
and he and i'm like i'm out i'm checking
the [ __ ] out hey you know what mom
there's a [ __ ] asteroid headed
towards my house i gotta go
imagine if richard branson was your
uncle you think he's talking about some
stupid [ __ ] like that he's telling some
dope at [ __ ] i'm [ __ ] hang gliding
with [ __ ] three supermodels hanging
up behind me
and there's too much weight for this
hang glider and somehow
i rescued him all still dude did you see
this video of this hang glider
uh where like they forgot to strap her
on like like they forgot to strap her in
and so she had nothing holding her but
her own fingers
yeah so she just had to hold on for dear
life i didn't see that
i saw the one where this guy jumps from
one cliff to another but he needed to
have the
bungee cord to him oh so he does it and
he jumps
and then you see the cord follow him
after and everyone's like oh
[ __ ] he could have [ __ ] died how
crazy is it that that chick who's
holding onto a hang lighter for dear
[ __ ] life
within three years just becomes a meme
for like me when i'm
getting a deal
like it's just wild to think about that
yeah you're mean brain that's funny yeah
you know i feel like i have much more
patience to learn things during this
time like
before quarantine i don't know why i
felt just
rushed for everything like i feel like
i probably paid attention 60 of the time
and just try to
learn [ __ ] really quick and move on to
the next thing but now
i can just literally sit here and just
keep trying to build a better skill set
with
with whatever hobby i'm getting into
that's cool that's awesome
okay i've learned too many hobbies and
then i still overload myself and feel
rushed
[Laughter]
yeah hence we're adopting kittens right
now so
fantastic a lot of kids you're just
playing another adventure
exactly another episode all right uh the
next one here
it says my father has pulmonary fibrosis
which is going to kill him in the next
year or so
it's a hereditary disease which has
affected three generations of our family
in a row oh man maybe you should stop
mating
you die from increased scarring of the
lungs
through research into covid there's
already a [ __ ] up more understanding
into
the reversal of lung scarring and
potentially a cure
on the horizon i'm not i might not die a
slow and painful death from this after
all
okay okay i'll take it back just keep
having babies because then and
like the next generation might keep that
might find a cure that is crazy though
the thing that
that come that that can be passed down
in your family like that where it's like
hey you
you'll die of this one day that is
pretty crazy it's like you see
death right there just waiting for you
kind of like diabetes in my family
or if you have multi-generational people
that keep drinking monsters and then
they drink monsters yeah
no there's no research on that there's
like there's constantly drinking it's
because they should have died but there
was too much
modern-day treatment so like they keep
passing in how did the placebo do how'd
the placebo group do i don't know
i just these monsters are just crazy
like an idiocy back to that movie when
they were all drinking just energy
electrolytes but it's got electrolytes
water you mean like from the toilet
okay next one that's literally how my
friend saw water and he got
diabetes from drinking soda oh my god at
18 years old
he's not even fat yep you know one of
the top things people say to me
in real life is drink water really why
are you [ __ ]
like i'm literally drinking a water
right now and it would that that will
never get well you did it used to
honestly of course i look at the glass
half empty dude they care about you and
they love you and
they're just saying i just love you
steve they're trolling me and i know it
and now you just gave them permission to
keep trolling
now they know it bothers you yeah it's
fine because it's just so fascinating
that that's what
is said he doesn't drink water
he does look a little parched thirsty
stinky
thirsty next positive thing that is
probably is that it's coming out of
covid is
it's already mitigated the stigma
associated with with working at home
there was a stigma yeah yeah that you
[ __ ] off and don't really work and [ __ ]
oh i mean like we got play jobs
it's pretty fun another one says more
help for
people with disabilities online ordering
grocery delivery food delivery it's been
nice
saves me energy when i can make an order
for something and do a contactless
pickup and they just put it in my car
when i drive up not everyone has the
energy
to spare for simple things like
groceries or errands and another one
a different one that someone else wrote
that has to do with disabilities they
said
honestly i think and hope it's going to
lower barriers
to work for people with disabilities
offices and buildings are supposed to be
ada compliant but that's only a small
part of it remote work
holds promise and opportunity for a vast
pool of talent who have been
sidelined because they can't get to the
interview or don't get the role
because they showed up with braces or a
wheelchair it won't reach everyone but i
hope it'll reach many more people whose
talent has been disregarded
how cool i didn't even think of that
yeah that's really cool
i didn't think people wouldn't hire
people with oh wait braces are oh yeah
leg braces
you're talking about teeth braces i was
like why wouldn't you hire someone with
teeth phrases
i guess i don't know everything they
smile no no
yes get out of here metal mouth no no no
no no oh it's another metal mouth no
we said no metal mouths you need to
check that you need to check the
document
i don't know how you came past the
screening
no one's [ __ ] wanting to smile around
another one says drive-in movies are
making a comeback oh yeah i've seen them
i was driving back from vegas and so
many
drive-ins were like off the side of the
freeway i was like wow i could watch so
many movies on this
road they suck you know they suck they
suck back then i'm sure they suck now
you don't know how to do they suck how
do they suck because in a movie theater
right it's all about the experience like
they have they spend so much money
on speakers because of all the sound
design and it's stark so all you're
looking at
is just the screen zero distraction but
how do you get a blow job then
yeah how you supposed to get blown like
that i mean you haven't gotten blown in
the theater
didn't you lose your virginity in a
theater i didn't yeah but i didn't get
blown i should have enough
so she ride on she wrote during x-men
too
yeah so she's still facing the theater
like watching it because she didn't want
to know she was facing me i was watching
the movie it was the part where
she wants the deal it was the part where
wolverine's [ __ ] up the whole mansion
yeah right he's stabbing people and i'm
like watching it while she's like
violence in my life you just
you're just not like move yeah i want to
see wolverine
well i'd already seen it at that point
so but it's still it's cool to see in
the movies
next one people with the clue what the
flu slash cold
wearing mess and taking precautions to
not infect others seriously pre-covet i
can't explain the number of times i've
seen people that were clearly sick
coughing wheezing and sneezing just
carrying on about their lives like it
didn't affect those around them
yeah that's a good point wait a minute
you lost your virginity in your late 20s
[ __ ] are you talking when do you think
x-men 2 came out oh never mind i thought
you were talking about the
recent one no not the new one that's the
logan he said
wait a minute yeah i was the person that
took his virginity
no wonder you guys aren't so so much in
love
no wonder you broke his cherry i like to
think he was a virgin before me
i like to think that too about you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you